[Musique]
la semaine dernière nous nous étonnions
de l'ardoisé laissée par laetitia à
l'enterrement de johnny vingt mille
euros de roses blanches impayés ça fait
désordre
quand on a pris de mauvaises habitudes
johnny il avait un train de vie de rock
star internationale pour des revenus
nationale et ça ne va pas s'arranger
pour le porte-monnaie de laëtitia
puisque martic la justice a suivi david
et laura en gelant une partie des
royalties de johnny l'argent de la vente
des albums il en avait été de même avec
les droits d'auteur l'argent des
diffusions en radio
donc c'est une victoire pour le camp de
laura et david on se souvient qu'il se
bat depuis 20 ans ont presque à relent
pour faire invalider ce testament
américain
laetitia voulait elle que l'ensemble des
droits musicaux s'envole vers son trust
aux états unis échappent ainsi à david
et laura et au fisc français
bah oui si le magot part de france pour
los angeles
inutile de vous dire que ni david neal
aura ni l'administration fiscale n'en
reverront la couleur la décision qui est
rendue aujourd'hui est une vraie
victoire c'est qu'on reconnaît que le
catalogue de johnny hallyday et ses
royalties s'ils sont transférés dans le
trust le seront de manière irréversible
le dernier acte de la saga se jouera en
mars prochain quand la justice française
répondra à la question essentielle en
remplaçant le débat de manière plus
simple
oui ou non johnny hallyday était
français ou américains pour laetitia ce
sera alors quitte ou double loi
américaine seule banque au droit
français c'est le fiasco alors laëtitia
est elle entrain doute père voilà donc
ça s'est passé cette semaine et c'est
très très important pour bien résumé
peut-être pour les gens parce que
c'était pas très clair même en loges
quand on en parlait pour tout le monde
c'est un peu de technique parfois dont
catherine est ce qu'on peut résumer ce
qui se passe exactement notamment au
niveau de l'argent des royalties non
seulement de ce disque mais de tous les
disques ces fameux 37 et demi pourcent
côté mis de côté voilà est-ce qu'on peut
expliquer aux gens il ya plusieurs
points les royalties sont donc les
revenus de tous les albums et quoi le
prix les derniers ça eu un jugement qui
reconnaît que 37 % c'est-à-dire en gros
la partie revenant à david et laura
doivent rester en sont bloqués pour
david et laura éventuellement en
attendant que le procès ait lieu
le reste laetitia qui est l'héritière
avec ses deux fils à elle principalement
par aux etats-unis peut-être dans le
trust on verra après ce sont pour les
revenus générés par les ventes donc si
on résume si on résume pour les disques
c'est bon hadj laetitia peut prendre et
62 % des revenus de johnny sur
l'ensemble de ses disques et les amener
dans le trust américain on verra on
verra seulement faire ce qui s'impose
aussi bien ce montant chabrat côté c'est
très difficile estimé
les chiffres le mr visa sur les albums
et les royalties et les 30 cette année
pour son ou ses vrais comme ça ça prend
une faille ça dépend du succès des
rennais qui s'est vendu à plus d'un
million les précédents qu'est ce que
c'est bon là ça va quand même pas mal
d'argent
après ce qui va se passer l'année
prochaine ce combat a parlé des droits
moraux c'est à dire la gestion posthume
des droits de johnny c'est à dire est ce
qu'on peut faire une comédie musicale
avec ses chansons les banderas
marque de soda ou à n'importe quoi ça
c'est là dessus qu'ils vont se battre
pour savoir qui gère les droits moraux
et là vous avez bien compris que david
et l'oral les revendique aussi alors que
johnny les a laissés cas laetitia
d'accord avec le noeud du problème avec
de savoir si johnny et est considéré
comme reese en français ou d'amérique
mais quand on est elle en train de tout
perdre nous détenons daniel c'est quand
même une grosse victoire alors seulement
les victoires s'enchaînent quand même
pour laura et david des week-ends
émission canal elle depuis le début cas
des procès là tout est à chaque fois
perdu 1 oui mais laura et david demande
est en fait que ce soit toute l'ailé par
des 80 ans je faisais à 115%
donc c'est une demi-victoire quand même
pour eux et si le 22 janvier donc c'est
dans pas longtemps
le tribunal de los angeles autorise
laetitia à mettre les sa part dans le
trust les les avocats sont tous d'accord
les avocates david le ca c'est un aller
simple les l'argent il dit que c'est
très technique mais donc les les
familles 62 % qui restent pour le moment
ils sont pas encore complètement acquis
à laetitia fin aux etats unis c'est le
22 janvier qu'on le saura à ça c'est
encore une petite étape c'est absurde
mais elle veut aller toucher par contre
ça quelques très concret c'est que
jusqu'à maintenant tous les trucs trop à
l'étroit maison disque de johnny avait
car je les gardais tout l'argent en
disant on va voir ce qui se passe est
trop compliqué on donnait rien à
personne
là le tribunal vient de dire finalement
elle peut prendre 60 5% à peu près 67
égale donc elle va récupérer de l'argent
qu'elles n'avaient pas d'accord vous
c'était gelé donc et après l'autre
partie bande en débattra en mars au
mouvement du corps c'est sur les mettre
dans le trust année permettra de les
faire échapper au fisc français je ne
dis jamais il était ce que l'autre débat
et les labos the border est elle en
train de tout perdre et quand même
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
l'autre débat évidemment c'est que je
sais pas si c'est une victoire est-ce
que c'est pas surtout une défaite pour
nous français parce que ça veut dire que
si elle gagne ça veut dire que tout
l'argent par là bas exxon ira pas au
fisc français et le fisc français bain
sans être un peu démago fait vivre nos
écoles nos hôpitaux et tout ça donc
quelque part est ce que n'a pas intérêt
nous français est ce que david et laura
gagnent tous leurs process guillaume
tout ça vous laisse un peu pantois
comment maintenant mais malheureusement
j'ai l'impression que tout le monde perd
un peu ses j'ai déjà dit moi je suis mal
à l'aise à parler de ça et oui je pense
que laëtitia petit à petit elle en prend
plein la ça va être extrêmement
compliqué pour elle et puis elle a un
peu perdu la bataille de
de l'opinion j'ai pas vraiment d'avis là
dessus parce que je trouve ça des signes
on l'a perdue depuis lors la seule
échappatoire pour elle sort et à terme
dans un laps de temps raisonnable
d'accepter de négocier c'est ce qui
permettrait même s'il a bloqué l'argent
et tous d'en finir proprement avec cette
histoire est peut-être qu'elle pourrait
encore gagner la bataille de l'opinion
n'oublions pas qu'il ya encore des
chansons à sortir de johnny absolue la
bataille du pognon bea avant avant qu'il
avant qu'il oeuvre votre sondage à vous
moi j'aimerais la vie de rachel pardon
c'est une question un peu piège que je
te pose mais est ce que toi ça te choque
toute cette histoire notamment de
défiscalisation qui fait que malgré tout
bas laetitia pardon est en train de se
battre pour récupérer de l'argent qui
n'ira pas aux impôts français
est ce que tout ça ça ne choque pas du
tout bien sûr ça me choque c'est je
pense que c'est important que quand même
david et laura récupèrent leurs dus
entre guillemets ham après c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué mais je pense qu'en
tout cas elle peut plus rester en france
laetitia
parce que moi tout ce que je sais c'est
que le choc un petit peu dans le débat
malgré tous ces clubs là on parle
maintenant c'est bon on a parlé de la
mort de johnny c'est touchant ce un vrai
artiste enfants restent calmes tout le
temps sur johnny sur donné et on oublie
de dire quand même que derrière tout ça
est quand même une histoire de fiscalité
qui est quand même très très importante
et qui est un peu dérangeante dans puis
surtout c'est que c'est les français qui
achètent des disques de toute manière
c'est pas avec un salaire c'est les
français qui achètent et lisent et
l'arsenal aux états unis donc là dessus
je suis assez d'accord avec note est
apte à bien d'autres d'années serait
d'ailleurs bien coup enfin johnny c'est
pas le meilleur fiscaliste de france il
a toujours voilà fait en sorte de payer
le moins d'impôt possible
voilà on découvre rien fait partie
acheter au contraire on découpe on
découvre on à son ajustement pour vous
est-ce que laeticia est en train de tout
perdre
oui à 66% effectivement m'excuser
catherine aussi sa marque les gens
chaque procès pour l'instant le père
donc la justice française quand même pas
de le percer en sa défaveur c'est à dire
que ça va là tous les jugements sont
rendus un peu en sa défaveur
absolument affaire à suivre en 2019